Kumail Nanjiani and we are so excited to
announce this year's Oscar nominees so
let's not keep anyone else out there
waiting it's an operation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
Stanley has an almost 62 year old man
happy Oscar nomination ladies and
gentlemen please welcome Academy
Governor Jennifer yuh Nelson hello
everyone and welcome to our celebration
of the 2019 Academy Award nominees for
Best Animated Feature and I know it's
very early in the morning in a very
heavy party week for some of these
panelists so I thank them for waking up
and shaking off those hangovers which
are really bad and being with us all
today thanks to the great Academy staff
for putting all this together so we can
share with you some insight into these
five amazing films
and thanks to the short films a feature
animation branch governor's John Blum
tom sito and Barney bonny Arnold for
their continued hard work and support
the branch John bloom mentioned at the
nominee dinner a couple nights ago that
the short films and feature animation
branch is now the second largest in the
Academy future animation elfia feature
animation has gone from being perceived
as a kids medium niche medium for kids
into one that is respected across a wide
audience and age with stories as
sophisticated as any live-action film
for adults one that is very worthy of
his own Academy Award this year we have
five films that span tone and medium and
time we have CG stop-motion and
painstaking hand-drawn animation we have
we have action-comedy emotion and
societal commentary the scope of these
films show the versatility of the medium
and the inventiveness of the filmmakers
as he pushed the limits of this craft to
guide us in the discussion today I'd
like to introduce academy short from one
feature animation Governor Bonnie Arnold
bonnie is a prolific and highly
respected film producer who's worked at
Disney DreamWorks and Pixar which is
kinda like getting an e got in animation
she is a Golden Globe winner and
producer for the oscar-nominated How to
Train Your Dragon films she has produced
such yes a third ones happening this
weekend she has produced such beloved
films as Toy Story Tarzan and even
Dances with Wolves she is also a
champion for women in the industry and
has served as a mentor for many
including myself who look up to her for
inspiration I'd like to welcome to the
stage Bonnie
Arnold
thank you everyone it's really good to
be here today as Jennifer said Wow I've
been doing this a long time I'm very
passionate about feature animation and
it's one of my greatest honors to be
able to serve as a governor of the
branch we have as Jen said we have five
nominated films we had 25 films this
year that qualified very impressive
number those 5 nominated films have
actually generated over 2 billion
dollars at the box office which is
pretty impressive this year we had like
the highest voting turnout in the
Academy and in our brand and the branch
itself among the members so it's really
it's really a great year for those kind
of things anyway this is a we're going
to a new format this year so the is the
governor who's moderating the panel
they're sort of letting the inmate run
the asylum which is amazing anyway I'm
excited like I said that start today and
without further ado let's see a clip of
Incredibles 2
looks normal to me when did this start
happen since Helen got the job I assume
she knows are you kidding I can't tell
her about this not what she's doing here
on work I've got to succeed so she can
succeed so we can't succeed it Bob I get
it
when what's the last time you slept
don't keeps track of that besides he's a
baby I can handle that I got this handle
so you good then you got everything
under control
right okay so he can still hear you from
the other dimension yeah that is freaky
and that's now not like our other kids
no it is not full powers totally random
you think so right obviously I can't
keep giving him cookies but if I stop
okay I think I just need a little bit of
me coming then I'll be good to go oh you
need more than meat and pop you need
major life realignment on a number of
levels
starting with baby super freak here you
need some solid outside the box thinking
[Music]
Kalbach II Elastigirl super suit is by
Kalbach e explain yourself diverse than
I thought it's the baby baby highly
unusual
[Music]
your luck gastly Robert I haven't been
sleeping I broke my daughter they keep
changing math we needed double-a
batteries but I got triple A's and now
we still need double-a batteries put one
red thing in with a load of whites now
everything's pink and I think we need
done properly parenting is a heroic act
done properly I am fortunate that it is
never affected me but you do not come to
me for eggs in batteries Robert I design
hero where I'm the last a girl must have
a new suit hmm you also wish a new suit
for the baby I would hardly classify
this as an emergency well he's a special
case we're studying if I could just
leave in with you leave yeah I am NOT a
baby person
Robert Oh baby facilities I am an artist
I do not involve myself in the prosaic
day to day to day Robert
Oh God
yes of course you can leave the baby
overnight I'm sure filling in for Helen
is challenging and you are very tighter
than the other children need you and
miss you has loads of them auntie Edna
will take care of everything so drive
safely and goodbye I enjoy our visits
I'd like to welcome to the stage
Bradford director John Walker producer
and Nicole Grendel producer
[Laughter]
that seems somebody change seats with me
so I just have to do obviously a shout
out for Brad
this is his fifth nomination he's had
two wins congratulations Brad this is
John's first nomination fun fun and
Nicole second nomination she was
nominated for a short previously managed
a super team absolutely anyway welcome
welcome so I want to give one caveat to
say that these folks and all the all the
nominees have had like weeks of
interviews and promotions and ongoing
and ongoing I tried my best to do my
homework and read everything and think
of some new questions it's really hard
but you guys haven't heard them before
so you're a new e to audience sorry gang
there may be some repeats here so just
to say Incredibles is actually I have to
admit one of my favorite movies are
probably my favorite movie over the
Pixar except for a Toy Story for obvious
reasons
Tway Story one and just saying anyway it
took like you know fourteen years
between the first film in the second
film so just in terms of I mean it feels
like there's a lot going going on with
that Brad was sort of this with the
success of the first movie was it you
know I know and I've read that you know
this has been something that you've
talked about but was there pressure on
you to sort of come up with a sequel or
is it how did that go exactly
oh are you saying that if a film is
financially successful that they
sometimes want to make another duh
that's not even you know yes if a film
makes money they always want another one
whether or not it's warranted and so you
know Hollywood has a long tradition of
that you know there was you know I mean
jaws - who would ever want to do jaws -
and yet they did it four times didn't
they yeah okay there's Godfather - there
is Godfather - there's Empire Strikes
Back there's a story - Toy Story 2 and 3
and and those are great Goldfinger is
the best Bond film in my opinion
that's the third one and you know so so
yes there are many good sequels yeah
there was pressure but it was it was a
it was a nice friendly not too pushy
pressure from Pixar well that's they
were friendly to you every time I'd see
Alan Bergman for ten years was when do
we get Incredibles - you're a producer
produce you know from my point of view
they weren't too pressuring but I guess
it really kind of had to be just right
and it really I think well I had the
idea for the role switch when we were
promoting the first film and I also knew
that we had the unexploded bomb of Jack
Jack which is that everyone the audience
knew that he had multiple powers but The
Incredibles did not and so if there was
going to be another film that was
definitely gonna be a big part of it he
was gonna be a big character in the
second film so those two parts I had
really early but it was the villain
story and and the story that is the plot
story is what was eluded me all the time
and it had to serve the other two
aspects which is the role switch and and
the Jack Jack part those are I were
committed to and so finally I had an
idea that I thought was good and I
pitched it to them they liked it
they gave us a green light we were about
three months into the green light and
and they took a year off our schedule
and suddenly we were like I mean last
summer was Toy Story 4 was supposed to
come out and it's coming out this summer
and they said will you switch places and
we kind of looked at each other and went
you know and and then so we committed to
that like taking a year off which I had
to put myself and ratatouille Iron Giant
mode of doing it fast and then we
realized that plot that I had pitched
them didn't wasn't panning out and it
was like then you have the very scary
question of do you put more resources
into making it work or do you bail
and because the clock is running and you
know we bailed and we and I went for
another idea that I thought was really
would work and is great and everybody
got excited that was our new idea and
then parts of that idea didn't work and
so it was continually like bailing and
killing darlings and you know it was
very messy you know but we came out with
something that would made some sense I
think I mean I think that's kind of a
reflection of being an experienced
writer director that you were able to to
bail more quickly probably than others
would and you had the confidence to bail
and ultimately I think there's and the
scars the terror
I'm just curious that Brad also does a
lot of his own writing and and as the
writer is it harder to write the hero's
story or the villains story I think your
goal in each case is to have an
individual and so if you're writing a
villain you want the villain to make a
certain amount of sense there there
should be points where you kind of go
you know what
the villains write you know and yet
there should be flaws and with the
heroes you don't want to just make them
good you want to make them flawed too so
I think that's the answer the short
answer is give them flaws you know Bob
is not great at assuming the dad role
when this film starts he's kind of you
know an alpha male guy who believes in
you know you just pound problems into
submission and you're done and that is
not required for this job so he needs to
be at home and he doesn't have the skill
set to do that well and so he's not a
perfect dad he's a flawed dad and there
was the scene that was incredibly hard
to write and get right where he and
Helen are talking over this thing and in
bed and you know I made him super flawed
in the first version and he was ripping
up a pillow and all this stuff and you
know feathers were going everywhere and
that was funny but it was a little too
over the top he was like starting to be
not sympathetic people were whisper
in our ears that you know he's not very
likable yeah talk to Brad he seems kind
of a jerk yeah so then you do the group
approved version which means which means
it's so you know vanilla that it's
boring as hell he's just a good person
in every way you know and that gets
thumbs up from everybody yeah he's
absolutely nothing so we can't object to
him like Mickey Mouse okay so so I got a
version that that was like as everyone
was like yeah he seems like a good guy
and I was like now I don't like the
scene because I want to see struggle I
want to see him fight a war with his
worst self and and I want to see the
struggle so you see him be a little bit
of childish and I finally figured out a
line that allowed me to bridge the two
and that's the version that's in the
film and for me that is the best of all
versions because he's a flawed guy that
you still like that was going to be one
of our first scenes into animation and I
think it was probably two-thirds in a
production where we finally well that
was safe it's just a bedroom two people
we run that one never that way so John
and Nicole when let me just ask you
something Brad don't listen but what is
it like to produce Brad Bird I mean ask
my mom I mean you know what I mean
can you tell him anything maybe does he
listen I mean you know well I needed
drugs you know what happens ample like
when you do have those pivots you know
when you have to like you know you know
you're gonna have to change course or
it's not really derail but you know
something kind of happens and all the
sudden you have to pivot the whole
John's kind of the high priest of this
art well I mean Brad and I have been
doing this for 20 years and you guys
work together back and and you know
we've developed
I mean Brad is an incredibly gifted and
responsible filmmaker you know he
doesn't doesn't want to go over budget
wants to make sure we release the film
on opening night which would be good for
everybody and but he always wants a
bigger film than we can afford right
it's it's always bigger than what
anybody is ever willing to pay so we we
have you know we've worked out a deal
it's like well you know you got a if
we're gonna do that then you've got to
listen to me and Nicole about what we're
gonna do when we we don't say no we just
say not now you know just all that but
you're good for you're good for it you
know it's like can't afford that right
now let's see if it actually survives
because of a lot of time you you work on
things you think are very very important
man you buff them up and six months
later they're cut you know so you have
to try to figure out how to move things
forward without you know spending too
much money
seems like you guys have worked together
before too so is there a little bit of a
shorthand in that way that you all the
three of you kind of work yeah yeah
absolutely I was on Incredibles and then
I worked with Brad on ratatouille and
John and I crossed paths a lot over the
years of Pixar so you know it was still
you know for me I think I had said at
one point at our cast crew rap party
that it was sort of like riding a
bucking bronco producing for Brad
because I had a lot to learn about
keeping those walls at bay and keeping
the crew positive when Brad needed a
little more space but you know that's
was one thing that was interesting on
this film is like that yeah I think his
sort of mythology precedes him so
there's you know there's a crew of very
young people who maybe never worked on a
film at all and they're and they're two
years into it I thought he was where's
my movie where's right also he's writing
right when he's trying to kind of you
know vamp a bit while writing the
versions that we don't do that's right
yeah I have to do those first and you
you know in trying to reassure that
group and some of it in some of it isn't
reassuring some of it's saying
them hey look this is making movies well
not be pretty for a long no like they
haven't been through this before a Pixar
but not the ones for the ones who had
been fought through it before we're not
the ones being freaked out as much the
thing is is that once we committed to
taking a year off the schedule which is
a lot particularly when there are
expectations for the film then there's
this urge to always say oh this is the
first screening of your reels right and
it's like it's not it's it's a bunch of
crap that we threw together and it
doesn't make sense yet and we're - we
have to show something so you're gonna
see it and it's gonna change it's gonna
be outmoded the moment you see it so
that's what it is and they kept trying
to get me to say so first screening huh
and I'd go no it's actually not a
screening it's just a bunch of crap and
and it's loosely around the theme of The
Incredibles and you know don't throw
that at us because what I said over and
over and no one listened to me until
after it was all over as I kept saying
the year has to come out of something
this is gonna be ugly as sin until it
isn't
and it'll be not ugly as sin right at
the very end I said it's going to look
terrible and just be okay with that
because the the what comes out when you
take a year out of a schedule is
reassurance you you can't have the 700
screenings usually have to make everyone
feel like everything's fine you you have
a couple of screenings and they're kind
of messy you know but you know we're on
it
we've done it yet for the giant trust
fall yeah yeah
I interestingly Brad I was just thinking
that you write and direct you've done TV
you've done features you do windows do
you do you do voices
right I'm just curious is there a talent
is there some talent that you wish you
did have I wish I had the talent to
greenlight my own movies you're greenlit
I don't know what it is but it sounds
marvelous
trust you completely
these can take control of the ad
campaign changing subjects a little bit
[Applause]
Michael Giacchino who's also one of our
fellow governors is their composer we've
worked with a number of times I'm just
curious if for the audience here he
could tell a little bit how that
collaboration works with Michael well
Michael's first movie score was The
Incredibles and you know we had a
certain style that I wanted to do which
had more to do with spy films than it
did superhero movies and I think it's
what when I was a kid the most
convincing over-the-top fantasies were
spy films they weren't superhero films
superhero films when I was a kid were
kind of cheesy and the actor playing the
superhero was invariably a little
overweight and and the effects were bad
and the music was kind of made fun of
the superheroes if you wanted to see
something that was over the top with you
know pet a with cat stroking villains
and and all of that you went to see
James Bond you know or Man From UNCLE or
Mission Impossible or you know those are
the things and Jonny Quest you know so I
wanted that style of music I wanted the
big brassy you know slightly
over-the-top kind of jazzy you know
sound and Michael had done video games
at that point and and a TV series called
alias and Teddy Newton recommended him
and when when I got all these
submissions of composers Michaels stuff
and it was done for video games so it
was kind of done quickly and and you
know one take with the orchestra because
they couldn't afford doing more than
that but he had amazing versatility he
could do a World War two thing over here
jazz inflected thing here or something
rock based over here and he seemed to be
a chameleon like an actor who could play
any part and I immediately hit it off
with him he came up to Pixar and it took
like a minute to feel like I'd known him
my whole life he literally it feels like
you're 10 and you knock on his door and
say can Michael come out and play you
know and he he totally understands story
and his music is a storytelling kind of
music a meaning that it supports the
movie that you're trying to make and
sometimes it goes with the scene
sometimes it goes a little separate from
the scene but it's a dance and it you
know I really love working with him and
I'm gonna our next film is my next film
is a musical that Michael will be doing
the music for phantom yeah so that's a
nice little tease for what's to come
anyway I have to say I think our time is
up I'll all come back at the end but
thank you all and this is the amazing
incredible team for The Incredibles
Thank You Bonnie thanks
[Applause]
so soon as they're safely off the stage
without tripping we're going to take a
look at a clip of Isle of Dogs
I wouldn't drink that if I were you
it's full of toxic chemicals how do you
know because my sister-in-law trying get
in her tongue turn black oh you're
Felix's maid
I beg your pardon I mean I think you
made it with Felix if I heard it right
that's none of your business
no no I I don't suggest whether it
actually happened or not I'm just saying
that I recognize you from when I heard
that rumor I think I'm gonna say good
night
wait wait wait wait oh no wait start
over
who cares about Felix I'm chief that's
my name
I see I'm introducing myself who are you
I thought you knew all about me all
right
I don't know anything they kept my mouth
shut it's all hearsay in any way you do
not make so you do know me after all
after all yes you a show dog no me I was
bred as a show dog was groomed for that
purpose it wasn't my choice I don't
consider it my identity anyway look
around what difference does it make now
so well that's a yes
so that's a yes I used to be may I join
you
[Music]
you've been attacked hmm
what else is new you should see the
other dog and actually I I think he was
made of stainless steel
I couldn't get my teeth into him who is
the little pilot and what do you do why
are they after him nobody knows
[Music]
you're a stray aren't you yes I am a
stray don't we all the last analysis I
mean were you trained for competition I
was a show dog you know a few tricks
then a few can I see one maybe if I get
to know you better
fair enough it's not true by the way
about me in Felix for the record I
wouldn't bring puppies into this world
[Music]
I don't believe in masters I never did
it's against my principles but this is a
no place for a dog like you you belong
somewhere
you've got papers oh I'm full-grown
sweetheart you don't have to worry about
me I hope I'll see you again here's one
one what I'm supposed to be spitting a
nine pound bowling ball over my head at
this point we just have to imagine that
part I can picture it will you help him
the little pilot why should I because
he's a 12 year old boy dogs love those
[Music]
I'd like to welcome to the stage
Steven rails the producer of Isle of
Dogs
[Laughter]
though Stephen you've first of all this
is a great clip and there's so many
little things that I love about the
movie but I love the little little
things I was there saying every time
there's a little fight there there's a
little cloud of dust that looks like
it's made from the cotton ball container
on my dresser it's just like little
everything in the stop motion technique
is you know looks is real and looks real
and you know everything from the little
subtitles I mean there's just so many it
so many great little things about it
anyway congratulations convention thank
you very much and congratulations to all
of the other nominees I think as
Jennifer pointed out at the outset to
see such different techniques applied
and animation is a wonderful wonderful
experience for all of us so thank you
all you you have worked with Wes
Anderson for quite quite a while now on
his live-action films as well maybe you
can tell us a little bit about how you
sort of you know came to know him and
you know it's been back from you know a
couple of movies just maybe a teeny bit
about that I think it's interesting sure
Wes and fellow producers Jeremy and
Scott Rudin's send their regrets Wes
Jeremy and I are working on West's next
movie in France right now we're in the
middle of production and the French
dispatch we hope to to wrap that middle
of next month so they send their regrets
and obviously they could tell you a lot
more than I can but Wes and I go back to
2006 when we first met and he had two
scripts one the Darjeeling Limited and
the other fantastic mr. Fox and he was
actually looking to find a place where
both of those could be produced by the
same producer or a production company so
we got to know each other and he's got a
remarkable sensibility a tremendous
sense of humility which I think makes
its way into his writing and to on the
screen and we became pretty quick
friends
it's been wonderful since this is our
six movies thanks right it's coming up
and he said also a bit of a Renaissance
man I mean he does writing and directing
and you know just a little bit of
everything is that do you know what you
know how he became interested in doing
animation and you said he already had
really had the fantastic mr. Fox
you know script when you met him I think
that animation offers Wes an opportunity
to explore his visual aesthetic in a way
that's different obviously from feature
films and there's a playfulness to it
there's an art form to it because so
much of it is handmade and I think he he
feels and has a sense that he can put
his imprimatur on a very different
medium right so something is good
because this definitely this is Wes
Anderson seventh nomination by the way
which is pretty amazing
he's in your second so congratulations
congratulations on that what what is
what is what do you think is that unique
thing that he brings to all of them
because when I was sort of thinking
about the different films even the
animated films there it feels like
there's like this quirky group of people
sometimes they're related and sometimes
they're not and you know whether it's
dogs on an on an you know on an island
of trash or you know a dysfunctional
family or something it feels like that's
there's some you know commonality to
some of those things well I do think
that that Wes has the ability to to see
and understand the the flaws and all of
us none of us is perfect and I think he
likes to explore both the positive and
the negative side of human beings and I
think in this particular movie he was
attracted not only to the imperfection
of certain characters but also to
Japanese cinema in particular to
Japanese woodblock prints from the 19th
century and with Kurosawa in particular
I think he was able to find a way to
inject his playfulness his sense of
humor the future and for some reason
trash along with man's best friend right
because I think I read a lot of it was
influenced by Kurosawa and some of the
work he did and he had this fascination
with Japan which is sort of like I said
the little touches in there the making
of the sushi and various things it feels
like it's a lot you know
just incorporated all this into the into
the movie that's right
Wes and Jason Schwartzman and Roman
Coppola his co-writers sat for a long
time staying staying committed to those
ideas of Japan the Future trash dogs and
the like lots of banter back and forth
and what eventually emerged as you know
what we have here and I think Yoko Ono
has a cameo in the movie I just love
that she does I know you were telling me
that that you did all the you know the
making of the film on both actually
fantastic mr. Fox and I love dogs on a
stage in in London so you got to go to
the set what was that like a stop-motion
set is very practical I mean they're
just it actually physically exists right
rather than in the computer that's true
it's it's a long process we began first
with our puppet design and I think June
of 2015 and began physical production
I think March the following year and
eventually finished in at the end of
2017 so almost two and a half years and
the puppet making process is pretty
remarkable in its own right
when we look at the two pictures Isle of
Dogs was actually a much larger in scale
and and effort then than fantastic mr.
Fox I think we had 70 puppet animators
70 puppet designers I should say working
on everything from sculpting to armature
to hair and makeup wig and the like lots
of hand painted activity Tracy the
American character and the film for
example has 321 freckles hand painted on
on each of 45 or 50 different different
faces the principle difference in
technology between the two movies was
the use of replacement faces and mouth
molds that gave the characters a much
greater sense of aliveness if you will
and three times the number of sets three
times the number of puppets 200 puppets
in one particular scene under the
municipal dome
so it was it was quite an effort if it
makes you feel any better I can't tell
you how many conversations we had about
hiccups freckles and How to Train Your
Dragon
I mean endless how many freckles how
they would look just you know it's just
difficult to do in any kind of animation
and those shots those crowd shots again
and you know 2d and CG crowd shots are
always complicated there's always a push
by either production or who's ever you
know paying for it's a less crowd shot
so it's very challenging it's a big
accomplishment to make it you know feel
grand and in the scale of what you I
would have you know been achieved and I
love dogs well I take my hat off to to
the animators I'm sure many of you
understand the plight of a stop-motion
animator but working behind the black
curtain hours and hours every day with
24 frames per second and moving the
armature you know ever so slightly to
create the realism so it's a remarkable
achievement kudos it's sort of like you
know it sometimes we don't like to tell
the boring side of animation but I think
in any any medium of animation there's
days when it feels like it's like kind
of like watching grass grow it's a long
process and interestingly some animators
are much better at creating action
others at creating emotion through the
way they're shaped faces mouths and the
like but they're all incredibly gifted
and Wes was able to find a way to pull
them all together and create a lot of
dogs and you were telling me too that he
is sort of in Cortland animation we use
an animatic which we you know do
storyboards and sort of get a very good
sense and I love about animation you get
a sense of what the movies gonna be like
before you sort of shoot it and you said
wes is like started to incorporate that
technique into his live-action
filmmaking absolutely correct the
animatic is the guidepost and we rely on
it every day and use it before every
shot it gives West an opportunity to
think through each shot from blocking
standpoint and the like so that when it
comes time to shoot we're ready to go
some of the actors refer to it as the
cartoon Wes what does the cartoon say
but actually it's an animatic for us for
the people that work in animation is the
Bible of what you know what's going to
be and you know you can figure out
before you spend a lot
money and time going the wrong direction
I think so it's a great it's a great
tool I read somewhere that you own
fantastic mr. Fox you actually did a
voice was that fun that was that was fun
was kind of remarkable is the the number
of ways and places that West recorded
people you know from iPhones to a studio
to the like and he's very exacting and
there could be multiple takes when
you're not on set and you can wear
anything you like and look any way you
like I think that's what a lot of the
actors actually like about it they can
just sort of roll out of bed and show up
and nobody cares as long as they you
know or don't have laryngitis so one I
thought there was something interesting
when I was reading that that if you say
I love dogs fast its I love dogs is that
you might be onto something
well if you do like dogs you definitely
should see this movie anyway I think
we've just about wrapped up so I
appreciate you being here on behalf of
the the I love dogs
you know producing and directing team
today that's very great for you to be
here and I'll see you again at the end
thank you very much and my congrats
again it's privilege to be in the
company of such great animation
okay moving right along we're now gonna
take a look at a clip of Mariah
daddy you want to play won't you go next
door and see if the kids want to play
but I want to play with you oh I thought
you'd rather be with mommy I changed my
mind
let's play yeah yeah that sounds good
let's read a book no wait let's watch a
video or we can play with tops all right
have you ever seen a whale I don't like
him right there boring hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on
[Music]
it's a real cookie
[Music]
make brother stop putting cookies on my
face already who are you and will you
stop hitting me and trying to make me
cry let's move past that we have more
important problems that are you be right
from the future a year for each day now
is your may not seem like a very long
time but what do you think will happen
when all of those years keep on adding
up I don't know tell me I might not be
able to marry the man I love that's what
who are you in love with well nobody yet
I just meant in the future you guys get
a raise
what are you talking about how should I
know just go tell Dad to hurry up and
put away the dolls already know why not
because I don't like you Mariah why
don't you like me because we don't get
along well you have to help me because I
can't let Dad see me why not please you
have to help me you're my brother I
never agreed to be my eyes big brother
ah fine I get it and I won't force you
to okay but if you won't help me then
you leave me no choice
we'll have to play the beat game begin
you gotta shake your little bottom hmm
and then you wiggle when you walk
ah well well Yami now yeah here we play
it again I'd like to welcome to the
stage the director Mamoru Hosoda the
producer you cheer Oh Sato and their
translator Satsuki Yamashita wow that
looks so beautiful so beautiful this is
your sort of son this is your sixth film
with Studio shizue what can you tell the
audience what would inspired you to
become a director
know your place Oh No
Kiko BOGO jibun jishin no sacred soukara
Akio get sake no kotoba Romanesco yes oh
no no animation sucking Oh yep I motto
Konoe say oh hello kiriona you know
Scotty koto hotel-casinos in there yes I
tend to make films that are inspired by
my own life and my everyday you know
daily life but I really think I became a
director because I really wanted to
explore the possibilities of what
animation can bring to everybody I'm
curious like I read that thank you so
much
I read that you're your son your young
son inspired this story and I was just
curious do you have a sister who on the
signal in Okayama Deva Kali mr.
Akutagawa giganto Nalgene set automatic
Adamo Oh No Tomoko
Mira I got my token so no Kerava solo
might assume conquer a story katakana
smokin OST stoic emergency janicoo
Naruto to the smoker emotive a Tokyo
target gene said vocal school image
connected so the Conewago scrotum
optimist yeah actually I'm an only child
and yeah so you know so of course my son
until his sister was born he was an only
child too so I thought he would like
really just live a life that I had
experienced but then you know then we
had a baby and then so suddenly he
became an older brother like he became
someone who has a little sister and I
was really jealous to see like what it's
like to have a sibling so that's why I
made this movie a little sibling rivalry
so my topic on Ocho de la patria sheet
the most negative PI video tool a
machine this unit yeah until then I
wasn't really like jealous of people who
has siblings but when I saw my kids
interacting I was I got really jealous
[Laughter]
and this is for both of you and Sanctus
on it as well what were the challenges
you think the biggest challenges of
making this film young sino takenoko
sujean conscious animation - yogyakarta
oh it's got a salute to go to my
poli-sci dimensional Ashoka I think the
biggest challenge was making a
four-year-old boy the protagonist of a
feature film so there are no canonical
apply batana Arnold sucking dick private
owner Koga in favor get a subpoena grow
my diameter if I say water there yeah I
mean I know like most of my films come
from my private experience my personal
experiences but when you know we started
to develop this film you know people
said why would anyone be interested in
your private life at home anyone else so
they can evoke onh van Scoy to move to
see almost Reagan our engine economic
all my muscle but me as a producer I
really thought like that would be really
challenging and interesting as well to
have a you know for your boy and look
into his personal private life you see -
son I know you've worked on all the
films with Hosoda son and and and what
does that been like over the years how
did you meet in the beginning Sakina
Pokagon you same token ended on the
scale more game were you saying your
name card on the cosas de Ojo Conan
another table on the scale of all so
Tokyo khakhra sort of tsukino Khanna
challenging in a sake mr. Kadam o
hadouken toka
ADA initiative the Cardinal scale animus
yeah so I started working with him
before a girl who left your time and
although that was that came out in 2006
we
the production in 2004 so I think I've
worked with him for like 15 years and
you know girlhood left through time was
also challenging but yeah I've been
working that long at Oh Oh God
I know sorry sizzles Karuma Anita Matos
DeKeyser de semana Sergio de Luca source
of the sake old school theatre bikini so
the kabocha artisanal shine produced
after that Dundas Kodomo called a carrot
oh the Elven this way yes we met we made
girl who left through time at a
different studio before we made our
studio cheesy at madhouse and you know I
was a like a assistant I was a producer
at madhouse and then yeah and then when
mr. Howlett I said like I want to make
this film like I was attached and that's
how we met I also read that that you
were thinking that this might be your
last film in in 2d animation because of
the it's just harder to find artists who
know the technique and just the cost is
that I wondered how you felt about that
and do you see that as is maybe just an
opportunity you know an interesting
opportunity for future for the future
might be the challenge Atika challenge
an economist tonight on tech aquino
animatronic they'll be [ __ ] a
psychotic oh no oh no Kamini and
Bacchus I even animation Duchamp
Okanogan burn me as action on scene
secured scotomas Kodomo sock on again
body even animation what Kamini
you know what it's could turn oh I don't
want a cup of tea Bridget's last cycle
the vitamins name yeah actually so it's
not really the last of the 2d hand-drawn
animation itself it's more of the
background
you know like because the backgrounds
were done I paint on paper and you know
after the people who worked on my
background they're currently working on
Miyazaki's next film but I really think
after that in Japan there's really not
going to be an opportunity for them to
paint backgrounds I'm on diet on today I
know
Boco a person coming in over the beat so
Kobayashi character Tom oh yeah Paisano
tell ikkaku Becky that today animations
caliber grotto motel on the moon Jess I
saw I saw
Nanako Nigerian Tony kuma Thomas not
really soon
technically I know animation would scoot
she's insane order now you know
submission Tina no a determined a swim
or knots could take two Guinea ganbara
knight to know Tony to come at ten to
zero
yeah I really but I really think it's a
big problem that the you know hand-drawn
technique is really like a little slowly
dying down because like you know not
just the background but I really think
the characters really need to be
hand-drawn and so I'm really at a loss
right now because thank you I think a
lot of the audience would agree with you
because I really feel like the content
that I really want to depict really
requires that technique so I really
don't know what to do oh no no totally
gonna net week so no Jen Bunney Glen
Keane Santosh Rajasthan degrom Glen
Keane somewhere potato de como un asunto
co2 salty vicuna
watch out till Hunico dia then we're
Parliament I the combo meter and a shoe
my shakedowns katana yes I think day
before yesterday we went to Netflix to
go visit mr. Glen Keane and you know
he's also very hands-on based so we were
both talking about like what are we
gonna do but then he had said like let's
not give up on hand-drawn animation so
thank you oh yes that I can only imagine
a collaboration between Glenn and Haas
understand that must be unbelievable
somebody get Glenn on the phone so go in
one box Angela Markham or some cash to
Monsanto poto
psyche colonoscopy no don't oh yeah I've
looked up to mr. Glen Keane for 30 years
I mean I love Beauty and the Beast so it
was really an honor who hasn't I mean
when is our national treasure for
especially for 2d animation I was just
curious and just going back to the film
it feels like in the story there's a dad
with a non-traditional role you know he
stays at home and works and takes care
of the children why the mother goes out
to work is that and then I read an
article that that's a little bit
relatively new idea that's sort of
taking you know becoming more popular in
Japan I just wondered was that an
intentional choice in terms of the
storytelling just sort of be an advocate
for that yeah they caught the mommy did
she go to stay with you no I know
yaponets kid oh yeah Python Chiquita so
they got a second and this kid oh yeah
Paisano Auto Sangha Yeti Hutterite a
focus on hepatic indebted routine
oco-2 the key go to this day kikuchi
from the egg oh it's good to know
so much shock I got him cash to excite
you the karate kata mangas name day so
you go to gender you do know captain
Tanaka Tomo Fujita you don't own son
take the Russia and walk sharing more
Alchemist energy work life balance mocha
machine and she saw you knock at the
baccarat image JSON colonic addicted
they so no Korea so technically
atashi cause of Kombucha death Mitsuki
Tico Tico - ma ma ago toaster no contact
a Sunni non communications type to
Montel cotton undies yeah so it is
actually happening around me like the
father was their home and the mother
would go out to work and you know when
when you think
you're gonna depict a family or take a
choose a theme that's revolved around
family you really have to like taking
into consideration of how the society is
changing like please we live in a
changing world changing times and then
so you know everything is evolving like
there's like work-life balance and
there's like work share and then you
know gender role reversals and I really
feel like I really um it's it's really
about finding what the definition of
what a family is it's really changing so
I really wanted to pick that in my movie
fantastic
I was just curious has led us on you
were very revered filmmaker in Japan you
have many really lovely movies the boy
and the beast wolf children the girl who
left through time but this is your first
Academy Award nomination and I just
wondered but you were how you were
enjoying the whole ride and what it's
been like for you to be an Academy Award
nominee so no no back in Co toka toka
toka Rona the a God's good Anika
descoteaux
mera hajimete an Academy show nominated
so no Connor Oscar no Tapio Thomas in
Damascus card on Okinawa kono sekai de
Kuna Coco Co Co Co Co Pina Colada
million desu kedo book on a chip on
Sasha America de ichiban Kaname Latino
vacati Carina in Jericho moutains
Nausicaa Tito Tommaso no koto mo catechu
decayed Pokemon Otonashi action when I
see Cochise minashi
nee Baga each misogyny American
concubine got Anita Nova
canoeing and Ana Muhammadan tilt our CEO
tada
community yoga the right evocative you
Tom de kado demos Oreos cuckoo you
Locanda create a nomination surrogate or
not the topic creationist oh yeah so you
know Amira was really released in 97
languages and many people across the
world have seen this movie but I was
really scared about showing it in the
United States because I was really
worried if the audience would really
accept
you know enjoy it because you know even
though a kid is a protagonist there's no
action there's no adventure there's no
car chase and you know every time I
every time I showed it in the United
States I used to say in my introduction
I'm just warning you guys nothing
happens in this movie but you know it's
really just about daily a boys daily
life but then after the movie when I did
the Q&A like they loved it they accepted
it so and then you know it led to
getting this Oscar nomination so it's
really amazing and I'm honored well it's
a it's an incredibly beautiful movie
with a lot of heart and congratulations
to you both
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you so much
[Applause]
okay
now we're going to see a clip for Ralph
breaks the Internet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I'll go with you and we'll be best
friends forever it's not right to hold a
friend back from her dreams you don't
order
that's not how friendship works you need
to let her go Hey you need to let her go
I know it's gonna hurt a little bit when
you do
Who am I kidding it's gonna hurt a lot
you're gonna be okay and we're gonna be
okay
right kid
of course we are always
[Music]
see no matter where she goes or where
she lives
she's always gonna be our friend you
just gotta trust her
cuz that's what best friends do right
[Music]
thanks buddy
wow I feel good about this
[Music]
[Music]
right here Ralph drill ouch jinkies
families Wow that didn't work
a pair it's a big strong man and needed
rescuing
[Music]
[Music]
oh thanks Frogger wait a minute where
are you
we're friends of vanilla peas yeah and
any friend of vanilla peas is a friend
of ours you're welcome I'd like to call
this stage rich more director Phil
Johnston director and Clarke Spencer
producer
[Laughter]
what a weird movie oh my god well of
course one time maybe in context that
seems very well we have to start talking
about that because again and some of the
things I read everybody loves the
princesses and I even watching it even
watching it today I just got a little
choked up when I heard the color my
world Little Mermaid my daughter's
favorite movie growing up so I think it
was a call back to all of us who had you
know that part that those moments in our
lives and anyway I just wanted I thought
maybe we could start talking a little
bit about I know you've talked about it
a lot but where that idea of using the
princesses in the film kind of came from
and was it you know in terms of
producing was it tough to get you know
even though Disney owns them was it
tough to get them to let you use all of
them and the scene and stuff good maybe
we can talk a little bit about we were
just saying we have ever many times
we've been interviewed there say 300
interviews probably 298 people asked us
about the princesses and we just
realized today the other two probably
didn't see the movie it's in every
article in every article favorite moment
in the movie I have to tell you it
always goes now we have to ask you about
the Disney Princesses you don't have to
know well it started as a joke really it
was like well what are some what are
some things they could do in the
Internet and someone said well it'd be
funny if Ralph took a personality quiz
you know an online quiz it said like are
you and onon and or an Elsa take the
quiz and somehow on an Elsa are there
and they fight over who Ralph is more
like you know and that turned into what
wouldn't it be wouldn't it be better if
we didn't have the princesses which was
a huge leap of faith you know that if
vanellope being a princess a Disney
princess or small small penis you know
if she met the Disney Princesses and
they talked about what it what it meant
to be a Disney princess and
well there's something there you know
and and it kind of morphed into those to
spoil the movie there's another really
great scene before this one was where
she's talking to them so you're gonna
see the movie and I think one of the
keys was when they pitched the idea they
all looked at me and said you think we
can actually do this going to your
question Bonnie on that side of it and I
said well the best way to do it is not
to talk about it in terms of actually
going and asking that you know
permission if you will but storyboard it
write it fill in Pam ribbon wrote the
scene we storyboarded it we edited it we
put it into a screening we told nobody
about it it was a secret within our own
story room and I said it's gonna live or
die in the room and if the room of
people watching it who are all
auditioning people love the scene then
we will have earned it and if they don't
then we're gonna know that piece
there'll be no way not to know it and it
was really fun to sit in the screening
room where we all kind of move forward
in the seats because another scene was
coming up to watch it Holmes
the audience loved it and from then we
had nothing but support in terms of
bringing it to life fantastic Phil I
know you and well you guys have
collaborated before but first of all I
just wanted to say in the beginning this
is Rich's third nomination
congratulations
this is Clarke second nomination they
both won for Zootopia right
is this your third no second second
nomination yeah yeah and Phil this is
for your first-time nominee but you but
you've been a writer and on the on the
other collaboration so how is it
segwaying into the director role this
this time around horrible
do not go well you know rich on wreck-it
Ralph the first one in and on Zootopia
we worked so closely together with with
me being a writer he is a director and
it was a we spend time in the Edit room
we worked the story together we worked
with the actors and he was of he's a
very democratic collaborator with with
writers and so other than spending a lot
more time together from A to Z and
making this movie the the the
partnership didn't particularly change
all that much I'm just curious
I'm just four
just as I've known Clark a long time but
I'm just curious for you guys what is
what is Clark like as a producer what is
what is it what does a good producer do
in animation well and I'm gonna let I'm
going to record the second sentence mama
have you ever had a have you ever had a
stapler thrown at you good
I have staple first by this man I Hrant
tyrant well when I first met Clark like
before the first wreckit-ralph movie I
knew immediately like this is the guy to
work with
because he's so well you know I'm he's
so he's so calm you know and he's so
steady Eddie even keeled and the job is
crazy you know it's like we get nuts the
production can get crazy it's like I
look for a producer that can build that
infrastructure that we can be crazy
around and who can be kind of the the
the safe Bastion and you know all the
the nuts that's going on so and he is
exactly that you know he's the eye of
the hurricane you know and it is it's a
bit of 800 ring circus and and I don't I
have no idea how you keep it together
all the while sort of hiding problems
from us so we can continue focusing on
what we need to with our various
delusions as we're going along and being
like yeah guys keep trying that knowing
that there's got to be a plan B C D etc
and and keeping us confident in in the
work I it's it's sort of Jedi like and
it's we're convinced that he goes home
and beats his dogs you know for hours
all night doubt that no no I think he
does you know I think I think he might
have started that fire out in Malibu
you know I he looks all nice and
everything well he wasn't a producer
when he went when he and I were together
at Disney but he absolutely aspired to
be in this congratulations thank you the
best the best I mean I've never worked
with any producer better than Clark I
have a question for you and I know that
you've talked a little bit about this
and some of the interviews but I think
this audience might be interested just
as the you know sort of the difference
you know that sometimes when you do a
first movie and you come back and do a
second movie the technology has like
advanced you know so much I mean it just
you know it can change between the
beginning of the film and the end of the
film honestly these takes so long but
just in terms of accomplishing you know
I read read that you guys had talked a
little bit about how are we gonna make
this Internet you know the look and make
this Internet work and it was complex
and it's just as we talked about earlier
it had tons of characters and I mean
what is that you know what kind of
challenges were that in terms of you
know in sort of layman's terms the
technology change and how that helped
you to make you know this this new you
know the second the second Ralph breaks
Internet yeah you know it's actually
when they the idea of the Internet was
in from the very beginning that's really
where the thought of doing a second film
came from and it seems like such an
obvious place to go but of course the
Internet is massive and goes on forever
and ever and so how do we actually
depict that so that became probably one
of the biggest challenges next to
actually figuring out the story is what
does the internet look like and how do
we actually bring that to life and
you're right what's interesting is I and
I find this fascinating is we don't sit
there and say is technology ready to
depict the Internet we say we're gonna
build the world of the Internet and we
figure out how technology can make that
happen and we have an incredible group
of people at Disney who we can give any
challenge to and they figure it out and
it really was size and scope there are
shots in this films that have a million
characters there's sets that go on
forever in terms of the number of
buildings into we could never have done
this when we made the first wreck-it
Ralph back in 2012 so it's interesting
to see all of that come together plus we
have a new lighting system called
Hyperion which really gives us a
believability to the character so we
didn't have before so it's been
fascinating to watch that all come
together I think it's it's a tradition
at the studio you know because I think
Disney Animation is always run on the
idea
of people will dream up these crazy
ideas and we have a team of people who
who will make it real it will manifest
it them that make it possible
right right I was just curious also I'm
going back to the clip and stuff I I
have to say I love the character of
vanellope I just thought she was
terrific and I felt like in this movie
that she was you know and I went back
and watched the first film and and she
was you know she was there obviously I
she was more of a supporting character
but now she's really I would almost say
it's a little bit her movie I mean she's
you know Ralph changes but vanellope is
sort of the catalyst for that change
so was that you know did that evolve or
that was sort of intentional in terms of
you know when you started coming up with
the concept for the for the story for
this for this you know it was
intentional in that we think of these
movies as two chapters of one story kind
of in that to your point we had only met
bunnelby for like 40 minutes or
something in the first movie and and it
felt like she had spent most of her life
as an outsider and she got what she
thought was her dream but what if we
started talking about what if she had
what if there were more and I think
that's something that kids can relate to
I could relate to that character when I
I'd been a journalist for 10 years and
when I decided to be a filmmaker because
I was asking myself well what if there's
more maybe this isn't enough and that
sort of theme just felt like something
that a kid like that would would engage
with and it didn't feel like her story
was finished and that we had to give her
a new sort of you know we think of it as
a two-hander but very much the journey
as hers she goes the farthest from from
from beginning to end first you had to
explain that to john c reilly well we
would say but Ralph changes the most
okay you know her journey is the longest
but he is the protagonist because he
does something at the end he's totally
different at the end than he is at the
beginning yeah yeah and that image sort
of was the the central image when we
started with the idea that it's going to
be holding on to letting go we didn't
know that it was going to be a
you know 900 foot monster that was
literally doing that but sort of that
central image of Ralph's Holdings too
tight and letting go was always you know
thematically linked to what I think it
helped you know prove show the story
because I think kids a lot of times are
very literal yeah the monster you know
it gives you something that's just not
just a concept but something you know
well and and we had this idea in the
beginning that instead of doing a
standard villain you know a surprise
Disney animation villain or or a fiend
that we wanted we said it really should
be in this story it should be Ralph's
insecurity as the villain and we had no
we had no idea how that would manifest
because just like how Brad was
describing it's like you're making me
you're you're building your parachute as
you're falling out of the airplane you
know and hoping to finish it before you
hit the ground you know so so there was
just the notion you know of insecurity
is the villain but I have no idea how
we're going to personify that but and we
tried you know a few times of like well
why don't we do a standard villain you
know and it just was not it was it was
not serving the story it was not serving
the theme so there was a point where we
had to say I don't know what the answer
is today but we're just going to have to
kind of run with it the that his
insecurity is the villain and trust that
we will we'll figure out how that's
going to be on-screen did but did John
and I'm just curious to John and Sarah
when you you know what to record them
when you've told them what the new
storyline was did they bring something
to you know add to that I found that
when you have the reprise their roles
they start to know the characters better
than you do yeah definitely and by the
end of the first movie they really knew
those characters inside and out so was
it was very easy for them to just kind
of jump right back into it and we've
record every scene of theirs with them
together because we like that chemistry
that comes from
but two of them times it makes it better
when they're absent their acting John's
only concern was that he didn't get to
sing a song that's true and there was
Sarah gets to sing a song and there were
really far too long for it to be a
reasonable request he's like maybe Ralph
should be in that scene too like why is
that will make no sense yeah but but he
want to sing that was that was his only
sort of complaint about where we ended
up I was there's another film that he's
in for it's I don't think has a worgen
situation it was in the mix called the
the the I think it's the sisters
brothers yeah I'm sort of watch that
it's a great film watch it I love
westerns but I was thinking that I
wonder if he was doing that weird movie
is the same breaks the internet because
like that was like wow three or four
weird movies at the same time it kind of
makes it fun I think anyway we're out of
time for at the moment but thank you so
much and congratulations and
congratulations to you on your new movie
How to Train Your Dragon 3 Bonnie oh
it's killing it it's doing it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so now we're going to take a look at a
clip from our fifth and final animated
film spider-man into the spider verse
[Applause]
but you don't have it yet I'm sorry
when will I know I'm ready you won't
it's a leap of faith that's all it is
miles a leap of faith
[Music]
[Music]
my miles is your dad please open the
door
come on as I can see your shadow moving
around yeah okay I get it I get it is
still ignoring me look can we talk for a
minute
so didn't something happened
look sometimes people drift apart much
dan I don't want that to happen to us
okay
look I know I don't always do what you
need me to do or say what you need me to
save them I see this the spark in you
it's amazing it's why I push you but
it's yours whatever you choose to do
with it you'll be great
[Music]
they'll call me when you can okay I love
you you don't have to say it back though
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
200 miles power with a blindfold on I'm
always asking what it I'll go kill
heartless of danger
what's up danger
the Sudha's the sparkle it's amazing
whatever you choose to do that you'll be
great our family doesn't run some things
you're the best of all you smile you
know your way you go and do I know I'm
spider-man
[Music]
[Applause]
that's all it is miles a leap of faith
what's up danger
like what's up danger lie what's up dick
NATO myself they fit perfectly
[Music]
[Music]
I'd like to welcome to the stage the
producing team of Phil Lord and
Christopher Miller and directors Bob her
Cecchetti Peter Ramsey and Rodney
Rothman in case you were wondering why
there were so many chairs there we're
the problem okay
okay we've got a big group here I just
have a question that was a guy that
looked amazing and I know this is
something that you guys the directors
have talked about in other articles but
I thought I'm gonna just profess my you
know 25-year ignorant sand would love to
hear it one more time about the look of
the movie and the fact that it was
animated I'm not sure in its entirety
but a lot on you know twos versus ones
and what does that really mean in terms
of getting the effect that you were
trying to do in sort of layman's terms
so that our audience can understand you
know what that what that's all about
go about everyone's looking at me yeah
yes now okay so two purses ones I mean
look when I started in animation
interestingly enough I had one small
credit before Tarzan was really the
first movie that I worked on actually
and I was lucky enough to be a rough
in-between or I got to work on Tarzan
and I learned traditional animation in
it at that point it was I think it was
you know also due to the fact that the
number of drawings you could do in a you
know over an entire production you could
put two drawings you can photograph
drawings twice and put them on frame
four to two frames of a second and
you're I wouldn't catch it and it really
made for a really powerful impact in 2d
animation and then we you know CG
happened and that became sort of the new
standard and in doing that we sort of
developed all these
that made hair real and cloth real and
but you needed a new image on every
second and so this thing of procedural
in betweens became part of the look and
feel of all these films and so in simple
terms it was trying to go back to fewer
images per second in the spirit for us
in the spirit of telling stories like a
comic book the way when you peel through
a comic book images have a real impact
in and they're they're drawn it's one
still image but it's drawn to convey
oftentimes multiple story points or just
something incredibly powerful or moving
and we found through image works and
some in experimentation that that we
could kind of recreate that with the
with CG animation on twos and it
essentially is a film that's animated
and on twos if it's moving really fast
it's on ones because just because of
spacing but I mean it really became sort
of the I think the foundation for making
the rest of the look feel so unique was
that the way it moved even supported the
graphic nature of the of the meat of
what we were aspiring to recreate
cinematically which was the medium of
comic books but in a larger scope and in
a way that moved in felt is it slowed it
down it just your eyes perceive the the
the image is longer in there in may for
some reason they just you know as we
started watching this stuff all through
dailies and stuff it was just you
started to get this sense of like I'm
it's just stronger you know and it's
just more bold and then with all the the
visuals that we put on top of it it just
supported that I just another question
for the directors and you know a lot of
times in animation you have a team of
directors that just you know over three
or four years it always it kind of takes
a you know a group of people to
accomplish it all but in terms of you
guys roles you know Rodney and Peter and
and Bob how did that work for you guys
in terms of your what you've you know
you're different your own superpowers
and what you brought to it yeah there
was a lot of overlap really we each have
our you know fields of
most expertise like you know Bob
animation me story Rodney you know
writing working on the screenplay but in
the middle there's this there's this
huge space of this the stuff you have to
do to get a movie made which is you know
we're all recording actors were all
directing actors we're all working with
the art department we're all in
editorial which became sort of the
creative hub where all of us would like
you know sort of like get into the
Octagon and figure out you know whose
idea is gonna win and what's the what's
best for the movie so it really is all
of us kind of parachuting in wherever we
needed during this kind of crazy fast
schedule we had and then you know when
when the schedule demanded that we use
our own kind of individual superpowers
you know we would focus on this and
Ronnie I know you were a writer on the
film but also you had written and worked
with Chris and Phil before on 22 Jump
Street is that but that you know ongoing
or did they you know have to call you in
as like an Avenger to help them on this
movie and that's I mean I got you know
maybe six months into production I came
on as a writer Phil called me and and I
read Phil's first draft I didn't I
didn't know what I thought before I I
was leading again away from it for
various reasons when you first called it
yeah you told me that yeah call yeah
yeah I did it's like totally unnecessary
but I because you said no afterwards not
I said this one might not be for me and
then I read Phil scripts and and 30
pages into it I I was in and then and
then after that I started to see where
the work was gonna be he was after the
first 30 pages you know of but I was I
was I was just like this is cool I was
like this story is cool this character
is cool these concepts are cool like and
and and I don't recognized it was
something that I had been looking for
I've been looking for something that
that was ambitious the way the way I
thought the project was so the other
button you just off of what these guys
are saying as co-directors you know we
all had different areas but
you know I think we all kind of were
interested in learning from each other
you know like that was a big you know
and that this movie has a learning
experience for all of us was a big part
of what kept us in it you know so yeah
I'm just curious Chris and Phil when you
know maybe you could talk a little bit
about the origin of the project I was
just thinking you know I can only
imagine when you know if it was you guys
it was spider-man you know and would I'm
sure there's no another spider-man and I
just remember when I was you know when I
years ago when I was doing Tarzan and
everybody just roll their eyes oh no
another Tarzan and he's just like you're
sort of fighting a little bit an uphill
battle so maybe that wasn't the case but
it just feels like you know so was it
was it did the studio come to you guys
or you know to sort of reinvent it or
just can you talk a little bit about
where that you know how that originated
yeah well about four years ago Amy
Pascal who was the head of Sony and and
one of your producers and one of our
producers and wonderful brilliant person
and has an amazing sense of story she
came to us and said what about an
animated Spider Man and that was that
was it and our first instinct was like
you to think oh another Spiderman just
what the world needs and but as we
thought talked about it and thought
about it we thought there are two things
that really seemed like opportunities
one was a different way of telling not
just a Peter Parker origin story which
which there are a lot of great versions
of but to tell Miles Morales story and
that seemed a really exciting fresh way
to talk about the universality of this
idea of an everyday everybody superhero
one that was a really inclusive idea and
felt like a fresh way in to the idea and
the other was the opportunity to make a
movie that felt like a living breathing
three-dimensional comic book so we went
back to them and said okay we'll do it
but only if it gets to be about miles
and only if it can look crazy and they
said yes and so that's how it started
well I think you you guys did and I I
didn't write this one down but I just
remember and I and
not a scene superhero movies I don't
have all the details super but it isn't
there's something about spiral anybody
can be spider-man right and I think you
guys did an amazing job of really we you
know just showing how that is so that
can be so true and so real and I think
that's why audience is just character
gets bitten against his will and this
these powers are not his birthright
their thing that happens to him and they
so I think that's what makes that story
powerful why it's interesting to tell it
a billion times about these different
people that this happen to because I
think on some level certainly all of us
on this stage I'm sure many of you feel
like you got bit by a bug that you did
do something and then you feel like you
have to do it and it's to be an artist
and it's gonna ruin your life but you
have to do it anyway
and if you're lucky you find some other
artists that make that art with it's
okay I think it's probably a little bit
like the first time I walked on a movie
set and I said this is what I want to do
I should have been a talk-show host
right guys you look great you're doing
great um I do want to ask another thing
this is I'm sort of fanning out here but
I thought the music was amazing and I
and I just loved it and I'm you know I'm
not an elder person and I loved it yo
Pemberton and I was going to ask about
Daniel Pemberton I mean you know he you
know he's relatively new on the scene as
composer and so and did but you guys
have worked with him before we didn't
met him a few years back and we really
we hung out a lot when we were living in
London together and we really we visited
him while he was doing score Abbey Road
for another movie and he was so creative
and he felt a little bit like Brian
Wilson doing Pet Sounds with and with a
whole Orchestra and we're like this
guy's amazing
and there's that scene in like every
music biopic where they're like wait a
minute that's shoe that's perfect get a
microphone that's like every day of
Daniels life
and every minute hey wait one minute now
did you guys walk on the crosswalk at
Abbey Road just asking I mean you know
this movie he was so creative he took
the whole orchestra an eighty eighty
person Orchestra recorded a score then
had it pressed onto vinyl and then had a
DJ scratch the whole score among other
crazy things that he did on this thing
but it has so much love and care and
specificity in every moment and so yeah
there's one scene in particular that I
think a lot of people just think is
music like like a like a scratch track
from from a previously recorded album or
something and it's when the - when miles
and Peter being dragged behind the train
and that's all score and it's it's an
orchestra - what Chris just said it's an
orchestra recorded and then pressed and
then scratched into score he's a keeper
I'm just curious is there
I mean having been through this myself
multiple times I was just curious to you
guys was there a moment at all struggle
and as we all have heard today all these
movies have these journeys where it's up
and it's down and it's back it's a
three-day weekends resonate after the
other three directors died but I'm just
curious was there like a moment I mean
it was it in a preview wasn't it I mean
it was thing we kind of really knew the
movie was kind of coming together like
you sort of hoped maybe maybe better and
different but kind of came together
after the premiere I'm here so I don't
know
yes and no yeah no I was just gonna say
there was that we were struggling for a
long time lots of hills and valleys and
more valleys and more valleys but there
was one screening December of seventeen
that it kind of started coming together
I mean it you know it obviously wasn't
all there yet but it was like the the
clouds sort of parted a little bit and
the Sun started shining through and I
think that was the moment probably that
to me that was the moment that I felt
like okay now we're all collaborators
instead of trying to prove the ideas to
each other now we can kind of see a
vision that kind of to me felt like it
really unified us as a team and we just
like and that kind of pushed forward
yeah and that was also right literally
two days before we released the first
teaser and so we at that point we were
desperately just trying to get every
image that was in the first teaser done
and we were still developing the look
and so there was a positive thing sort
of narrative Lee for the story for all
of us and then we released the teaser
and then we had a reaction than the
studio was very happy because the people
believed the look and they and that just
gave us a lot of momentum for to try to
essentially make you know almost two
hours of a movie in 11 months which is
kind of what we did and I think of that
screening it was really clear that you
were following miles and you cared about
him and that family story was going to
work nothing else was working
no but that was the core words and you
could tell that the people making the
movie were onto something that was like
really clear it on the granular level
yeah well I do have to say that I mean
if you look at all the sort of the
thread that ties all the movies together
here today is I think they all focus in
some different way about families and
family relationships and I swear that
gives me hope because I think that's
what the audience is really respond to
and you guys have done an amazing job
congratulations and all first-time
nominees by the way so
be amazed thank you anyway I'm gonna I
want to make time to call everybody up
to the stage so let's just take a moment
and get everybody up here
yeah thanks everybody bring some more
chairs look oh yeah the nominees will
come up
got everybody sitting we have just a
little bit of time left but I thought
it'd be really you know this is our
tradition that we have everybody come up
here together we have a nice great big
group so congratulations to all of you
again today enjoy I just want to say
having been through it enjoy tomorrow
there's nothing like it you're gonna
remember it forever it's really gonna be
a great day but I just wanted to I was
just curious that also do I have a
couple things to throw out there I think
all of us who work in the animation
business know that we're all going
through this giant sea change I feels
like the ground is sort of shifting
there's just so many things that are
going on in terms of platforms and all
these kind of things is that I mean to
you all of filmmakers as directors as
producers is that scary is that exciting
what what makes you excited about what
we think is going to be the new new to
me it's a blend of things I mean there's
a Gold Rush II feel right now which is
familiar to anybody that remembered when
everybody was trying to do Disney
musicals and there was a suddenly if you
could hold a pencil for more than three
seconds you got employed and and so a
lot of films were made a lot of not very
good films and then the gold rush died
away and a couple of good films got made
in that accidental scrum too and there's
a little bit of that feeling now there's
a joke on South Park where it's at
Netflix and they they answer the phone
by going Netflix you're greenlit can how
can I help you
and so right now we're in another gold
rush and some hopefully people will take
advantage of the fact that nobody's
minding the store and quickly make
something great before they get yanked
away from it the standpoint it's
challenging to find all the talent to do
all of this but for anybody out there
who's looking for work in animation you
are in a very good
you're greenlit Edgar inlet
well I think I think definitely a lot of
a lot there are a lot of people in the
audience that want to do we're lucky to
do what we do every day and I just was
curious if maybe a couple of you could
chime in to tell the audience of what
you would you know what do you love
about your job for these guys I came
originally from live-action I had a
great experience there and I'll
hopefully continue working in that also
but I every day like working on this
movie I would I couldn't believe how
many talented artists I got to work with
every day and collaborate with and I'd
really meet it like I it just kept me
energized during all the periods we
talked about when it was really hard I
would just get into our sweat box or
just me start talking to people and I
couldn't believe how much everyone was
contributing and it uh it felt like a
superior work environment than men to
what I come from and and I'm excited to
do a lot more you know it was great to
build on that I agree that you know film
itself is a very collaborative art form
and animation itself is I feel like the
most collaborative art form that exists
and that you get to work with hundreds
of people that all get to have a voice
and have an opinion and have their art
be seen by millions of people so it
that's the best part to me is that you
it really is a team job and people can
build on each other and make something
really special and and they're
passionate about it I mean it's the
the big takeaway for me from from our
movie was you know we had a huge crew
but everyone it was like a hundred ten
one hundred fifty percent dedication to
our characters our story the the you
know the new techniques we wanted to use
you know the guys at Sony image works
you know our genius production designer
Justin Thompson these people were like
they lived and breathe to like find
something new and exciting and
interesting to say through the movie and
you know it's you don't get that
experience very much anything I don't
think you get that opportunity very
often in in in this industry because it
is such an expensive sort of medium you
know these things take so long and and
as you were saying Brad there's like a
certain amount of reassurance people
need at the end that it's all gonna get
paid back but there's something that
happens when maybe you do have less time
and people are given a little more
freedom you see that you do have
especially in animation it's incredibly
passionate creative artists who given a
you know a problem to solve usually do
it in a way that's unexpected and pretty
spectacular so that's I think that's
hopeful and to me the fact yes the I
mean there are three films that appear
that come from sequels and an existing
property so it's going to contradict a
little I'm about to say however their
animation in terms of the big-budget
Hollywood blockbuster type movies is
really the only place you consistently
find new ideas and property that just
comes out of someone's brain and it's
allowed to be set free into the world
without having an existing IP attached
to it again I'm contradicting myself I
realize however I think there is there's
so much opportunity for that that
doesn't really exist in Hollywood
anywhere else well can I just stop for
one second and say talking about
cruising I meant to do this earlier if
there are any people in the audience
that works on any of these films here
today can you
stand up for a second I'd love to
acknowledge you all anybody that worked
in support of any of these films I guess
the rest of them had enough I just know
it man
it takes it takes a village right gang I
mean we all know that we work with tons
and tons of people are the unsung heroes
and all the credits right yes one thing
I wanted to interject though is that I
am hoping this gradual acceptance leads
to something where actors see us as
fellow se animators as fellow actors and
not as the enemy I think that there is a
a feeling that animation is
technological that we press a button or
throw it into a ma of a crowded you know
craftsman and and that the film emerges
but people that are animating scenes get
into them if the scenes are emotional
the people are emotional doing them
they're doing them at a slower rate but
they're just as invested in giving a
great performance as as any actors so
that I hope that we are seen as as
fellow filmmakers and not as a separate
thing that's I think it's Jennifer
Nelson said in the beginning I think
more and more it's always our desire of
the folks that work in animation to get
out of off the kids table into the into
the room with the grown-ups and more and
more that the things that we do get off
the kids table yeah okay we're on the
table we have apple in our mouth being
served I'm not gonna go see that unless
I take my child I said well you're gonna
enjoy the movie really anyway by
yourself but I always lead with the kid
my kids love your work
you go do you hate it but I think the
day's audience is an example that there
you know there's people out there that
are actually older than you know Tim
that can actually enjoy animation enjoy
movies so I think we're totally battling
this audience of the table okay thank
you for coming today thank you can I
just follow under what Brad said as may
be the only film up here that was rated
pg-13 but but I I just wanted not just
to echo but to emphasize that throughout
our picture west continue to emphasize
that let's this is a movie that we're
making this is not a cartoon and because
technology has assisted all of us in
bringing our stories to to the outside
world I think what we're seeing on the
stage here from all of these films is
evidence that story emotion characters
really matter so I'm really optimistic
about what this medium can do in the
future and I'm excited to be a part of
anything that has these kind of
collaborators so thank you anyway has
anybody else have anything to chime in
today that we didn't cover we did they
done miss some question that I should
have asked because I think we have to
wrap it up we have two we have the
makeup and hear folks coming in after us
but thank you congratulations again to
you all enjoy and good luck tomorrow
thanks Bonnie
thank you all
[Applause]
you